what does he Fletcher terrorizing Gotham
Daniel day-lewis ill-advisedly bragging
and Leonardo DiCaprio getting mauled by
fair all have in common they each used
method acting to prepare for their role
Heath Ledger isolated himself for weeks
to portray the Joker's chilling
psychosis Daniel day-lewis spent months
and character before filming even began
if I say Illinois would agree and
Leonardo DiCaprio really went into the
woods and got mauled by a bear kidding
he ate raw bison liver instead each of
these performances received an Oscar but
unless were actually told about the
extreme lengths these actors went to
there is no way for us to know which
back to the question if Leonardo
DiCaprio really eats raw bison liver and
nobody is around to see it does he still
get the Oscar needed to be done because
we're striving for authenticity and
modern method acting is based on a
system developed in the Soviet Union as
a way to structure training for actors
the system provides a framework for
actors to understand their characters by
drawing on their own experiences and
imagination many method actors take this
to extremes pushing themselves to live
as if they really wear their character
but our intense method acting
performance is really better if you just
look at the numbers the Academy seems to
think they are since 1951
there have been 132 Oscars awarded for
Best Actor and Best Actress and 59 have
gone to actors with some training and
method acting and 33 of these Oscars
specifically went to actors who used
method acting techniques to prepare for
the role but there's more to method
acting than just winning Oscars there's
been this kind of evolutionary dynamic
between watching an actor just for who
they are their screen presence their
persona versus how they inhabit or
interpret a character take Tom Cruise
for example whether he's fighting a
mummy fighting Morgan Freeman are
fighting the shogunate it's impossible
to see Tom Cruise as anyone but himself
[Music]
does Tom Cruise even know the names of
the characters he's playing anymore what
is your name this creates a problem for
actors they become captives to their
star personas look at Leonardo DiCaprio
for another example
despite being nominated five times as an
actor Jamie Foxx he didn't actually win
an Oscar until 2016 and he won for what
happened to be his most intensive method
acting role I don't know who goes
through the stronger emotional roller
coaster really and physical your
character so what the audience me so
taking on ambitious method acting
performances can help actors be taken
more seriously but there might be a more
cynical reason behind method actions
popularity really have seen method
acting become a marketing tool doesn't
matter how good your performance is
unless you have a really good
behind-the-scenes story to accompany it
Hollywood is a business and businesses
need marketing when Daniel day-lewis
goes on Oprah he gets to promote his
movie while also highlighting his own
work as an actor I begin to hear a voice
kind of a fingerprint of the soul
there's no way for actors to show us all
the work that goes into a role so they
have to tell us instead my reaction to
eating that piece of meat is right up on
screen but that doesn't mean method
acting is all about marketing either
after all it helps Leonardo DiCaprio go
from this
to this it really caught on in terms of
transforming the appreciation of an
actor from being someone we just enjoy
watching on screen to being someone who
really is consummate in the craft who
works tirelessly to do justice to their
character and serve the role as best as
they can
actors that have pursued intense method
acting routines have created some of the
most memorable performances ever and to
be fair to Leo if I draw a Bison liver I
would tell people to